belle tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono fa vj e oggi
vorrei fare un video un po speciale dare
innanzitutto siamo su amnesia da secoli
non facciamo windows e amnesia è dato
che siamo in periodo natalizio anche se
ormai ha passato faccio e commenta ricco
il cappello di babbo natale m finita
anche il pon pon nell'occhio è così
faccio babbo favi ecco perché alla
variante alla mappa che siamo così mi
rendo già più ridicolo già mi rendo
ridicolo per gli spaventi ma così ancora
di più
begin sentite questo è il mio saluto per
voi a rizzi ok ragazzi allora questa è
una mappa di amnesia un po particolare
me l'avete consigliata perché avete
detto che è molto natalizia e date
verranno fatto una ceppa per voi come
regalo di natale perché dato che il cane
nuovo non ho avuto tempo di fare tanti
video ho deciso di fare questo questo se
mi regalo che poi non è un regalo ma è
un viso solo dove io mi metto il
cappello e mi rendo più ridicolo di
quanto già sono normalmente
ora siamo già mezzi morti ok perfetto
una stanza bellissima tra l'altro ci
sono anche i mobili nuovi ragazzi tipo
questo qua dopo natale già passato
sommese e nettamente ma babbo favi
ancora no ok non ed è lì che mappa sia
questa me l'avete consigliata perché
avete detto che è fantastica tipo questo
è un computer nel 1800 un computer
perfetto farmi controllare facebook
togliti ok non possono entrare facebook
già perché la sedia non si smuove allora
dopo ok perfetto
ok adesso posso fare babbo favia tutti
gli effetti come si fa a metterlo dietro
tipo ma forse non si può fare la boa i
regali li porto in tasca a messaggi
fuori youtubers un record is this isola
a dar is a lot of music and in this fall
conversion but don't worry dell'isna
copyright music
ok se non ti mandavo massima a casa
allora babbo fa vi è pronto per portare
i regali a tutti i mostri di amnesia
ragazzi perché si sono comportati bene
quest'anno non c'è carbone ok frigo per
qualcuno ha lasciato qualcosa per babbo
fa vi si land of a serial il download
come sempre lo trovate in descrizione
per chi lo vuole giocare ma vabbè dai ma
da buon babbo natale il quale sono ai
soldi grad mai jacket fares questo no
passo investiti a terra normali
forse questo no si è questo ok adesso
sei contento possiamo uscire usciamo
show
ok perfetto tenetevi pronti ragazzi
perché babbo favi
ok remix christmas remix ragazzi non so
che cosa devo perché si accendono le
torce da sola e phan fah vijay incoming
e porta tanti presenze loading ok
perfetto torcia permesso c'è nessuna
qualcuno di ostile no si ragazzi però
non sa cos'è questo fa un pannolino
jenner santa a questa è la lettera per
me deve far vj faccio finta ci si trovi
già sono stato buono quest'anno e questa
è la il mio la mia lista di cose che
voglio per natale e questa è la mia
lista di natale i miei due denti davanti
perché gli udenti frontali questi due
dead or alive hunt santa fa vj donald
quindi vuoi che il buon babbo favi ti
porti due denti davanti ok andrò a
prendere a pugni qualcuno e troverò due
denti per te perché sei stato buono
quest'anno io andrei avanti già così
perché non c'è più voglia di controllare
i cassetti
perché dovrà accogliere lettere di
natale c'è una rosa e per me
grazie che bello a questo a questo
ragazzo qui spero che sia una ragazza
magari meglio però porterò dei regali in
più sono stato buono quest'anno prometto
vuoi un violino fa vigenti porterà anche
un violino porto tutto in tasca
andiamo tra l'ultima stanza ragazzi è
fantastica ma che cazzo è successo ma
porc ok questa ragazzi non me
l'aspettavo perché c'era un babbo là
c'era un mostro col cappello di babbo
natale nell'armadio perché spiegatemi
perché non ci trovo il senso e che ci ha
anche lasciato la barba la prendo io
ragazzi perché vi serve
se un attrezzato solo di cappello e a te
non ti porta una ceppa di minchia sai
perché perché ti sei nascosta
nell'armadio e mi ha fatto paura a
questo qui è un pezzo del cavaliere ok
cosa ha chiesto una sigaretta
grazie mille mi serve dopo quello che è
dopo lo spavento che mi ha fatto
prendere devo rilassarmi
anche se non fumo però batterie va bene
io andrei avanti
ok chiusa come fa a essere chiusa forse
ragazzi ho lasciato qualcosa nei
cassetti tipo no ci deve essere qualche
cosa un piede di porco questo mi sarebbe
a spaccare i denti davanti al tipo
perché devo portare un regalo a quel
bambino a lima ha chiesto a due denti
davanti quindi mi ha lasciato
gentilmente il piede di porco per farlo
oppure semplicemente aic ben fa vj babbo
favi anche scassinatore ragazzi salve
dovresti essere a dormire se no niente
regalo
sì però stai calmino cioè anche home e
maionese nov sono qui per portare i
regali dirlo in su e nessuno e di star
calmo stop no ecco come fa babbo natale
a portare i regali a tutti c'è i portali
non ci avevo mai pensato ma va perché
poi ragazzi il babbo natale non dovrebbe
soltanto portare i regali invece non si
deve prima fare il giro a raccogliere
tutte le lettere e poi portare i regali
che palle cioè non lo pagano mai
abbastanza sto povero babbo collect all
aids bass cos'è islanda
siamo entrati slider ragazzi collet all
eight pages ma dai facesse lander i non
ne siamo da quando mai la presa per per
il capra anzi questa va beh entriamo
ma veramente lui raccogliere pagine c'è
mysland erin amnesia a buono entriamo ok
ma c'è qualcosa
anche i suoni quelli this land e ragazzi
ma si può
ma chi è che ha fatto stava malato di
mente ma perché c'è testa niente ragazzi
non c'è in ogni video che faccio lo
slider deve essere sempre di mezzo se no
non sono contenti vedo qualcosa laggiù
fantastico ok posso mica la casa dei
nani non posso entrare però c'è una
pagina permesso questa casa dei puffi
ragazzi non si pente troppo bassa
ok siamo a due ragazzi non ci credo di
sì anche se gioco che ne so
hello kitty chase land perché sono
destinato a giocarci cos'è sta roba cosa
siamo entrati in egitto ragazzi c'è una
pagina qui per caso
no niente pagine per babbo favis invece
3 su 8 ragazzo finendo anche perché lo
slider manca quindi è un bell'aiuto
diciamo che l'audio della c'è più quello
vero almeno c'è anche il mega deal due
ragazzi proprio l'asl andarci anche il
mega dildo e famosissima mega deal del
primo slam there
quindi ragazzi è poco c'è ci siamo o
quasi vinto magari riesco a vincerlo per
la seconda volta perché dopo quella
volta lì non ho mai più vinto
ok c'è qualcos'altro di qua cos'è sta
roba
la galleria oddio oddio questo lo sa
raga
ok allora provato della pagina e io l'ho
guardato prima
peccato non ce ne sono state tranquilli
però era soltanto per emulare il primo
infarto che ho avuto nella mia vita che
è stato fattivo nato lo di natale questo
è il mio posto ragazzi parole di regali
siano già per caso ma solo intervista
fottendo al lavoro no perché sono io che
devo portare i regali bedini non
fottermi perché non so dove andare e
fantastico
oddio cos'è il pozzo e siamo a sette
ragazze manca una fa chi è ha peccato
non ce lo slider non ce lo slider ma
comunque sia è fantastico ok ok ok ok ok
8 ragazzotto pagine 88 fa chi è a tutti
che non c'era lo slider cioè ma
scusatemi ragazzi è stato lo slider più
difficile che abbia mai fatto in tutta
la mia vita otto pagine sono qualcosa di
fantastico
anche perché cosa lenta non si è visto
una volta
sì non c'è voglia di leggere anche
perché dovrei tradurre ho preso la
muletto del re ok torniamo indietro
calvi bravissimi ei torna indietro non
si muove ragazzo non si muove carri a
chiusi nell'armadio che è successo sono
tutti i babbi natale del mondo sono
gelosi perché io porto i regali di loro
il mio cappello e chi bello cos'è raga
sono gelosi perché loro portano i regali
ma non riescono a farlo bene quanto lo
faccio io
ormai l'ho già prese le lettere di quei
poveri ragazzi non mi venite a prende
però abilmente stavano cercando le
lettere di quei ragazzi di male ho già
preso io quindi fottetevi
ecco visto se ne sono andati il mio
compagno è più bello ok mi hanno anche
gentilmente lasciato il cappello e la
barba anche loro però non mi serve
potremmo conti sono ragazzi e fantastica
sua musica cioè cerac mani nov in al
mese a fantastico che poi ha fatta bene
come mappa perché dunque c'è un casino
di roma nuova a parte i nostri col
cappello che sono peggio dei troll ma
che non mi si accende la torcia questa
una porta che per must be a che in anni
erbil rom
probabilmente la chiave qua dentro
propri ma non mi ci faceva entrare
adesso vinci fa entrare
ok raga babbo fa vi sta avendo successo
o peggio di quei mostri perché comunque
li sto battendo sul tempo e li sto
fottendo tutti i regali
loro vogliono rubarmi il lavoro ma non
ce la farà noi mazza che grande cosa c'è
qua a parte che buio pesto e non vedo
niente perché non c'è uno straccio di
batteria mazza che corridoio e salve
posso entrare
fate entrare grazie
c'è qualcuno che ha bisogno di regali
[Musica]
anche tu ok non ho capito cosa mi hai
detto però mi fa piacere parlare con un
maiale diciamo che mi aiuta a capire
quanto ancora sono sano di mente ragazzi
ho bisogno di batterie assolutamente
batterie qualsiasi cosa per delle
batterie raga o no non sono batteria dal
finder box cosa vuol dire cos'è che è
successo non vedo niente
[Musica]
che cazzo madonna siamo certo nord sono
a casa o no corda in etichetta
ok fa missione sono uscito riuscito ok
ok sono babbo favi dovrei essere
abituato al freddo vivo al polo nord
invece no sì però 6 vanno alzati forza
non può farmi niente un po di freddo
sto via ok ok ok poi genere potevi
semplicemente chiedere gli facevo fare i
regali non li portavo più io è compito
tuo portare i regali qui stai tranquillo
non ti tocco niente portali tu o mio dio
questo ragazzo è stato forse non so se
al livello di quello dello slider però è
stato veramente pesante
oh mio dio